si vous devez laisser votre smartphone
de Samsung en réparation et vous ne
voulez pas qu'on ait accès à toutes vos
photos et plus confidentielles à votre
carnet d'adresse et à toutes vos
applications voici comment faire c'est
une nouveauté sur why 5.1 vous allez
dans vos paramètres et dans vos
paramètres vous allez sur batterie et
maintenant de l'appareil et ici vous
descendez tout en bas et vous avez un
nouveau mode qui a fait son apparition
c'est le mode maintenant et le mode
maintenant sur ce que vous l'activez
votre téléphone va redémarrer et vous
pouvez remettre votre téléphone très
facilement à quelqu'un puisque la
personne n'aura plus accès à rien du
tout pas à vos photos elle ne verra pas
vos applications personnelles elle ne
verra pas vos contacts elle aura juste
accès aux applications natives sur vos
smartphones et ça je trouve ça
extrêmement rassurant d'ailleurs vous
dites-moi si ça vous est déjà arrivé de
laisser votre smartphone en réparation
et que quelqu'un tombe sur des photos un
peu compromettantes marquez moi ça dans
les commentaires